some good cigars to go with all those
cars over there some big news for the
Big Smoke weekend Casa Fuente inside the
Forum Shops is unveiling something
special and strong to complement the
cigars owner Michael fry is here to
explain how are you great good for
having me thank you for being here we're
excited about the Big Smoke I have some
family who come in for this weekend and
are very excited about it yeah it's the
biggest cigar event of the year
so what goes on at the Big Smoke what is
it for those who don't know so it's for
cigar lovers who come from all over the
world it's two nights at Resorts World
this year they buy a ticket book they go
in they get about 30 cigars food they
get to try all kinds of different
Spirits listen to music it's a
tremendous time that's a good time now
this is big for Casa Fuente oh yeah it's
our busiest weekend of the year because
when people aren't going on a specific
night they come out and hang it at our
place so it's it's wonderful to see old
friends and do a lot of business
definitely it's a now Casa Puente is a
cigar lounge but also a company a Cigar
Company too well the Fuente family has
Arturo Fuente cigars and we're partnered
with them in the lounge bar and we've
been there for going on 18 years now so
it's been a great partnership and great
partnership with the form shops okay
well speaking of part Partnerships we've
got a big reveal happening here at Casa
Puente there's a new bourbon that you
guys have fixed right so uh bourbon's
one of the hottest Commodities in the
world now it's even getting more
expensive than gasoline believe it or
not but we found a great company called
rare character that finds Scholars the
country looking for great barrels and
they do specific barrels for different
types of company and it's nice because
one of the principals lives here in Las
Vegas now oh okay so what are the
flavors of this special bourbon well
this this particular bourbon has been
aged in Sherry Cass so it's nice and
sweet but it has some nice spice some
chocolate and vanilla notes it's
definitely a sipping bourbon okay so
that sounds good to go with your cigars
during big smoke but also for the
holidays oh it's it's a great gift
because this is a one-time Barrel so you
know we have about 192 bottles and
that's it because each Barrel has its
own characteristics also this is super
exclusive so really quick tell everybody
how they can come down and celebrate
with you guys well I'd come down on
Saturday because uh Carlito Fuente will
be here signing bottles from 3 to 4 30
on Saturday and I expect to sell out in
one day so come down on Saturday all
right get smoking